we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
i have to tell you um i'm worried
that i am just terrible at communicating
with my audience and what i mean by that
is
um sometimes i think i'm being clear
about what i'm saying
and then i get a voicemail like this one
and i start wondering
what the hell is going on with my
communication skills maybe i really
can't express myself effectively this is
related to my story
last week about what's going on in haiti
and explaining
some of the racist analyses of the
economic differences between haiti and
the dominican republic
and then i got this voicemail take a
listen
david sir sir
talking about man and i'm talking about
the segment that you did in regards to
haiti
yeah and the dominican republic okay
saying that
we come from a european descent
which i absolutely disagree being
dominican from the dominican border rate
in the dominican
matter of fact if you pay attention
to any sports that includes dominican
players
most of the players that you will see
are not of
european descent right we have
old range of colors when it comes to
people we have black
we have whites and we have a lot of
in-betweens
right and for the most part
we are compromised in in the population
i'm talking about
of people that are either of dark skin
color
listen what i explained last week
was for people who may be aware that
haiti and the dominican republic share
an
island the island of espanola
but haiti is significantly worse off
economically
i wanted people to know that there is a
very common racist
story that's told about why the
dominican republic is better off than
haiti
the story that the racists tell is
haiti is mostly people of african origin
black people whereas the dominican
republic
is much more significantly comprised of
what we would call
latino and european origin meaning
white people now the actual
breakdown is that haiti is almost
completely african
whereas the dominican republic is only
11 african
16 percent white slash what we would
call european
and 72 percent mixed which includes
european and other things okay i wasn't
saying
the dominican republic is a european
country
i was explaining that the truth about
the disparities between haiti and the
dominican republic
are quite complex and they relate to
geography
they relate to weather they relate to
deforestation
and that jared diamond has written a lot
about this that's the real
story the wrong story is that
there are people who like to just say
haiti is worse off because it's mostly
black people
and the dominican republic is not and
that's true but
am i really i mean should i quit is
there a
i i feel i don't know if it's me or it's
somebody else
but i feel like i am not i must not be
communicating effectively as i was
trying to say this is the story that's
told
it's a wrong story okay let's move on
we have a great bonus show for you today
the world health organization is warning
against mixing and matching coveted
vaccines but many people are doing it
and i know people in fact that have done
this
we will also talk about the gavin newsom
recall in california
and we will talk about millennials
living paycheck to paycheck
on over 100 000 a year okay all of those
stories and more
on today's bonus show don't miss it
sign up at joinpakman.com to get instant
access
and i will see you then